hidey ho gamers carl what are you
holding a diamond
so carl you're probably wondering what
do you do with that diamond i am
wondering that jimmy what do i do
i'm going to release a horde of 100
people and you need to take that diamond
and get as far as you can oh
gosh we have a scoreboard on the right
and we're going to have dozens of people
compete this challenge and whoever gets
the fur this gets a ten
thousand dollar diamond in real life so
first start the first challenge i'm
going to show you guys what i mean by
demonstrating it
boom the gates here fell and the gates
on the other side of the map fell for
100 players
oh as you see an army of people in blue
armor
are now rushing carl we're coming for
you carl
the further he gets the better chance he
could win i hate
chris carl they're coming after you carl
carl
screwed me all my homies have always
hated chris
carl made it 99.6 meters all right
i got two hits on him dude 30 seconds
dead
carl we're going to swap you out for
someone else on the blue team signer i
never liked chris not even one time the
ender bow is our second contestant how's
it going man
it's going great is that because you
have a deep voice uh i'm 15. now andrew
before we start your obstacle course i
need to introduce dream hi
if you don't know he's a youtuber he has
like five subscribers all right let's
start it server
oh go go go if you get the furthest
distance with without dying
i will buy you a ten thousand dollar
diamond in real life stay less hold up
left side left side hey where are you at
you're currently in first place why are
you jumping towards the people
okay the plan didn't go as planned okay
the plan did not go as planned
if it makes you feel better you made it
10 more meters than carl so as of right
now
you have won the 10 000 diamond i'll
take it how about for this next one we
have a dream
be the runner let's see how far dream
can make it okay dream how many meters
do you think you'll make it well i don't
know we'll have to see i think i i could
potentially finish it
you tell us when to start uh psych start
the challenge
i love trolling dream it's so funny oh
it's a dream
oh no what are you doing i'm doing
better
than them that's what i'm doing already
he's already in first
um oh what was that he's on the right
side
right side getting some hits on him oh
he's dead oh no
dream you made it 155 meters that's
pretty good i bet you technoblade would
do better i'm not gonna lie void squid
do you know what you're doing i think so
perfect start it up all right let's go
go as far as you can
i'm going i'm going let's get avoid
squids going down
oh he's coming i don't see people oh
oh man that was i beat carl yeah so
that's a victory
next hello howdy do you know what you're
doing
uh kind of chris your turn all right the
farther you go
the better place you get the better
place you get
diamond it's so complicated server drop
the gates just run
just run as far as you can and use your
fireballs oh he's a left side on the
left
i'm gonna help her i'm distracting them
stay
by go away and chris is hitting people
careful that he's on the left side
robo no oh oh no oh my gosh you actually
made it pretty far
dream i'm gonna put it on you you have
to explain the challenge to the next
person i don't want to do it
okay all right so stop come stand here i
have something very important your job
you have a diamond you have to pick a
kit
you get to the other side you win if you
get there quicker than everyone else
okay go yes i'm in first
i'm right behind you i'm actually pretty
close wow my server responds faster to
dream than me
go cover more ground stop
loop-de-doopting and start
scooty-tooting
yeah you gotta scoot i'm behind you boy
jedi oh
don't jump down don't jump down oh oh my
goodness
oh my gosh big brain oh my goodness
oh all right you're in first place
you're in first place get um
go go go go go go oh hey all right
how far did he go 177 super kai
dream got dethroned just crouch if you
can hear me
all right start the challenge let's go
i'm helping him i'm helping him go run
go he doesn't have a working mic nick go
can i have a redo can i i was taking i
was using the bathroom you can have a
redo if you say subscribe to mr
beastgaming
everyone better sub to mr b theming and
mr beast
and whatever other channel what is he
doing he ran
backwards since he said subscribe to mr
b's gaming he can have a reading i feel
like we should help him
you do scout and we'll do the damage for
you drop the gate
go go go go go let's try to obliterate
them for you
ah i blew myself up all right so far no
one's on
yeah you got time oh they're all over
here
oh you're rainbow uh he just rambled
into a whole crowd though wait where are
you oh they're right behind him oh
oh my gosh you are seven meters behind
soup
everyone's on top of each other no one
knows where he is we should let chandler
have a go
chandler i'm so nervous drop the gates
i got you chandler oh the nether right
sword does no damage
wait wait oh did you use both of them oh
i didn't mean to the catch the water
catch the water
no chandler i hit you off chandler
you're in third place
that's not bad that's not bad though i'm
better than the dream boy jedi is our
next contestant how's it going
i'm pretty good what about you good did
you already blow through the ten
thousand dollars you won in the first
challenge
no i have not okay now i'm gonna need
you to stand right here we're gonna have
to handicap you all right server
drop the gates all right i don't i don't
want to hear anyone saying oh you
favored
this person that person we're being fair
that sounds fair to me
what class did you pick the feather oh
my gosh why is no one else got in the
way
oh my gosh oh my gosh he's gonna make it
to the end
we ran right past you bro
have you played this map before i've
been scouting it out i told chandler my
plan earlier
he beat it in 45 seconds that's gonna be
hard to beat what up new guy
hello are you gonna beat boy jedi i
don't think so
that's the spirit all right drop the
gates all right i'm gonna go help you
out by spawn trapping them
whew i'm throwing fireballs stop got
oh you guys killed me we're just carpet
bombing them you please do i need all
the help i can get him hurry you gotta
finish in 45 seconds to be in first
place
go up chandler you killed him ah
chandler we're supposed to help him i
have a present for you give me one
second
uh here's a camera right here hold it
just go get some mcdonald's or something
invisible i'm happy to report that we
sent chandler to buy 69 chicken nuggets
so you don't have to worry about them
killing you this time i'm off to
mcdonald's again
because apparently i blew up the
contestant and i wasn't supposed to do
that
drop the gates i'm dropping tnt don't
worry guys we're good
uh i fell jump jump jump jump yeah
go go go uh i really
suck i mean guy we got you a lot of help
there i did my best uh what's up uh
what's your name leno mini the server is
voice activated say
server drop the gates all right i said
it and it listened to me i'm sorry it
was listening to you yes yes yes
wait is chandler just there afk i wonder
what he's doing right now oh can i get
the 69 chicken nuggets
there guys just embarrassed myself again
oh that was a good try next
mr strategy go i i haven't played
minecraft in forever
and go go over here go go go don't miss
no keep going if you stop you're not
going to win don't stop don't stop
all right oh they're waiting for you oh
oh nice nice nice nice
who are those people it's boy jedi they
knew they knew they're out
server i request a one-shot kill sword
i request one too no campy dampies 69
kids yeah we're like
oh hey chandler's back hey
everyone cheers your nugget on three one
two three cheers
boom and now that we cheers our nuggets
let's get to business
ikea for life why are you so passionate
about ikea
i'm from sweden there you go so i need
it okay you ready
yeah wait how's this person already out
void squid was already out i don't know
where boy jedi is
oh oh big brain you got one more rainbow
use it here use it here and you
might be good all right good good good
good we got to protect him get away
get away get away my sword is not one
hit oh there's a tunnel down here
secret tuttle oh he died oh
no and now the moment you've all been
waiting for
that dream guy's gonna go again i'll
beat him i'll beat him don't worry
i'm gonna help him out a little bit
though all right i'm ready whenever
techno's watching show him who's boss oh
wait jimmy has to
eat mayonnaise or something i delete the
footage i didn't make a reference to
dream and techno i don't know what
you're talking about
oh oh so how's he gonna get in the
portal oh my gosh
oh my gosh wait you did it in 41 seconds
oh sucks to be boy jedi right now
mr boy jedi dream beat your time but
dream got two chances which is why i
want to give you a second chance we
gotta be fair
okay now that i think about it i think
we should give boy jedi three chances
let's do this you got this boy jedi
you got this i hope he do it all right
so you're doing the same path
yeah i mean it worked the first time oh
oh oh
jedi come on come on
my gosh that would have been it you
would have beat him by one
second boy jedi you literally have to be
perfect on this sport
all right let's do this drop the gate
yo help me out we're helping you as much
as we can how are they already fishing
dude i swear they literally run here and
fish
why i'm being fished again they found
the fish of me
yeah get him get him get him let's see
it
one more time one more time am i able to
see the other pass because i've only
really scouted up the middle path nope
all right
let us know when you're ready drop the
gate can
he win no no no okay jump jump jump oh
oh okay come on come on protect me carl
all right let's see jeddah you got to oh
no he knocked it
off there's like a thousand people right
there
jedi you didn't get first but we are
still gonna give you a prize for second
place
five thousand dollars and dream
congratulations you get a ten thousand
dollar diamond just uh
tell me your address real quick and i'll
ship it all right my address is